[Music]
dokie tell me hello everyone and welcome
to another month of pewdiepies
literature club that's right
2018 is just full of surprises I've been
loving reading all your comments about
suggestions and and what you thought
about my suggestions and ideas and it's
been a great time I had a lot of fun
reading this month as well we got a lot
of stuff to go through
did you do your homework we're gonna
discuss the books that I said I was
gonna read I think I got all of them
why don't we just jump into it I really
got to say though it's been so much fun
and for for me to discover how much joy
you can get out of reading I know it
sounds really maybe obvious but you
always hear people say oh it's so
important that we worry read and it's so
I wish more people would just read but
people never say how fun it is to read
it's like I completely forgotten I
wanted to start off with recommending
this book called I am Legend I think
this is a great book if you haven't read
anything in a while and don't really
know what to get into it's very light
and it's very gripping from the
beginning to the end it's a story about
Robert Neville who is the last living
man and he's bunkered up in his home
because at night
vampires comes out and they want to they
want his blood they want to kill him
they sort of tease him and taunt him to
get him out of his house because he's
bunkered himself up in a way that they
can reach him protecting himself with
garlic and just following Neville in
this horrible horrible scenario that the
vampires wants to kill him and he can
only go out during the day if it's Sun
sunny outside immersing myself into that
horrible scenario was so wonderful in a
way I don't know how to describe it
otherwise Neville is a scientist so he's
sort of try and make sense out of the
situation and make sense out of the
super supernatural in a way thinking
why are they afraid of garlic why do
they only die if I poke him with a with
a wooden pole it was just really
interesting to follow and apparently
this is the book that popularized
popularized life anyway that made ad
pocalypse scenarios popular like the
zombie fad or whatever which for someone
that's so sick of that idea this was
ironically so refreshing you may be
familiar with I am Legend because of the
film with Will Smith and he does follow
it pretty similarly similarly I can't
speak but in the film they're zombies
there were these weird zombie thing but
it's but it's like the vampires that's
the point of the book you can't just
change that completely miss the whole
whole idea and the ending of of this
book which I won't spoil of course but I
will tell you it was one of the it gave
me chills it really hit me hard it's a
very clever and interesting ending that
really stuck stuck with me and I loved
it for it I thought it was entertaining
from the beginning to the end and that's
why if you haven't read anything in a
while you can definitely get into this
if you don't mind reading a horror and
I'm giving this 5 out of 5 stars
hooray next up we have June which oh boy
I said I wanted to read more sci-fi so
ton of you suggested that I would read
June this is apparently what people say
even here at the back it says the
greatest science fiction novel ever
written
it's about this desert planet called
Arrakis that contains the most valuable
element in the universe which is the
spice melange which is this spice that
can be used for many different things
but it gives you the ability to increase
your lifespan it allows for interstellar
travel to be possible but to harvest
despise you do put yourself at risk from
these giant earth worms
so and it's an extremely tough landscape
water is a currency in itself almost so
it follows the story of Duke Leto a
treatise his wife lady Jessica and Paul
who gets caught up in the conflict
between the houses that are trying to
fight over control over the planet
because whoever controls the planet
controls the universe because you
control the spice they get caught up in
the conflict and that sort of where the
story takes speed in my opinion it's
weird because they really spoil a lot at
the back of the book I definitely don't
recommend reading in the back of the
book but I was literally 200 pages in
and I thought to myself this hasn't
happened yet we haven't gotten even here
yet so the book takes a long time a long
time to really take speed in my opinion
but was it does it's an amazing journey
that I love taking part of unfortunately
there are so many names and so many
concepts and so many characters that I
got really lost the first few hundred
pages I think that's why people love
this book so much because it's so
incredibly rich but since I didn't pay I
think as close attention as I could have
done I would have enjoyed the the last
what is it 300 pages a lot more if I had
paid more attention because I constantly
had to remind myself okay what was that
again okay what was what was that I kept
forgetting and it was hard to honestly
it was hard to keep track on it
nevertheless I loved it I loved
following the journey it was badass to
say the least
it's interesting how June is such a
popular and well-loved sci-fi but it
does have a film made out of it it even
has a game I think maybe I'm wrong but
it never got really as popular as a lot
of what it inspired it was clearly
inspired to Star Wars I can see a lot of
resemblance I think Game of Thrones even
the creator of that even said himself
that he was inspired by June this
clearly inspired so much of our
entertain
but it hasn't really reached that mass
appeal it's it's not nearly the biggest
Star Wars I think someone said the
reason why is because it doesn't really
have what what what made sci-fi popular
back back at when it was written it
doesn't really have robots it doesn't
really have computers and these were the
things that people wanted out of sci-fi
back in back in the day so it'd be
interesting if dune somehow makes a
rebound and gets remade into another
film and if that becomes popular or not
that would be really interesting because
or maybe a TV show or something like
that since there's so many Arabic names
you can have a diverse cast in there and
Studios can pat themselves on the back
and be like wow we did such a great job
it takes place in the desert it's about
harvesting the most important element in
the universe controlled by the rich it
has a bunch of Arabic references are you
talking about oil
perhaps Frankie Frankie Herbie I think
this book can definitely be interpreted
in different ways even though it's
really just a badass space adventure
given it four out of five stars
June was the book I said I was gonna
read did you read it as well did you
share my opinion about it I'm not by any
means saying what I think is right or
wrong but it'd be interesting to know a
lot of talking I hope this is all right
I don't feel feel very self-centered for
me to do all the talking but please do
share your ideas as well I do want to I
do want to hear it now moving on I
wanted to read Murakami Kafka on the
calf cap was London Kafka on the shore I
read this in Swedish because I wanted to
brush up my Swedish skills but she
didn't really help
Kefka on the shore is the story about
self-fulfilling prophecy it's a story
about a young boy that runs away from
home and you follow him in one chapter
and then he alternates to another
character which is an old man who's not
very bright but he can talk to cats
and he's looking for some things you
have a character running away and then
you have a character looking for
something in it and one at the beginning
of his life and one at the end of his
life you sort of see their stories come
together but the old man can talk to
cats somehow and it's a very very
surreal story it almost feels like a
dream at times when you follow it it is
very honest and open about the fact that
it's the story retold in a way almost
the story of the ancient Greek mythology
of odd APIs
I think it's called odd APIs which if
you're not familiar is it's the story
about a king that was told to him a
prophecy that his son would kill him and
take over his wife and so he banishes
his son to try and stop this prophecy
but the prophecy still gets fulfilled
anyway he ends up the son ends up
killing his dad and he ends up with his
wife it's very twisted sort of tale and
so is this book definitely it's filled
with the metaphors and it's categorized
that's surrealism which I can definitely
agree with because of that I don't think
this book is necessarily for everyone I
think with Murakami's storytelling it
seems that the feeling is more important
than the story the the mood and he
spends a lot of time explaining and
describing things that might seem
trivial and that might be a bit tedious
if you're not really on board but it's
funny cuz Murakami even admits this
himself in the book he sort of leaves
you hints on how he thinks you should
interpret reading which I thought was
pretty funny Murakami's presence is very
clear in this book which I actually
really really like I feel like I'm
learning who he is by reading his work
which is really interesting even if you
don't understand everything in the book
and what it means it you can still draw
your own conclusion and if you're
completely wrong that's okay that's B
that's besides the point at least that's
a
and I picked up on another hand was how
he really does love describing things
that might seem trivial like I mentioned
and he even mentions Dickens himself
that he would spend I don't know 20
pages just describing how a cabin looks
like and you do get a lot of that in
this book as well feel like I have to
mention since it is the story of
self-fulfilling prophecy about ending up
with the wife his mom it does contain
incest which genuinely disgusted me now
I I know Morikami he's a pervert and so
am i but I did not appreciate those
chapters I can't even pretend that I
enjoyed it it was just disgusting and
because of that I don't know if I should
be recommending this book to everyone I
will write this book still four out of
five I still really loved it and I I
really look forward to reading more and
more akame I love his work are you still
with me everybody yeah now after reading
June and Murakami which are pretty hefty
novels I wanted to read something more
simple something lighter I know I made
other promises of books I was gonna read
but I I just I I thought I need to break
with something so I decided to read
American Psycho which is a very dark
satire comedy and it's about Patrick
Bateman which is this Wall Street worker
who is rich he is handsome he's charming
he's successful he's great in every
single way but he's a psychopathic
killer so you basically get to follow
the life of Patrick Bateman his internal
monologues what he goes through every
single day and the interactions he has
with other people and just following
that was so funny I think there's like a
whole chapter just describing the brands
of of the things in his apartment which
might sound really boring but it was
hilarious
I found myself laughing out loud so
often while
reading this which was honestly great
what's really scary about this book is
that how much I don't think it's just me
I could really relate to Patrick Bateman
maybe it's the YouTube or ego I really
thought about that a lot how I think
we've all been in the situation where
how do I describe this so I don't seem
like a psychopath if you're in a line
and you're in a hurry you immediately
start thinking of everyone else as a
nuisance they're in the way they're in
your way to reach your goal since
Patrick sees himself as such a perfect
person as such a elitist being he really
sees everyone else as and as a shallow
person they're they don't even compare
to him and I think that's what becomes
his demon because because he puts
himself in such high regard everyone
else becomes completely insignificant
and he that becomes his pain he wants
other people to feel that pain and it
goes extremely dark and extremely
graphic with its violence and gore to me
I can understand if that would turn some
people off and I don't think I'm like oh
I'm so edgy I don't care but it wasn't
really that bad I guess I don't know it
doesn't go on overboard at least it's
very interesting to me how even though
he's a psychopathic killer you still
really like him and I thought a lot
about why that is why do you like this
horrible person is it because we do care
so much about these positive traits that
he does have like he's handsome and
sophisticated and rich or is it because
you sort of just get attached because
you follow along I don't know but it's
an interesting question number tha less
and it's a great piece of satire and I
really loved it four out of five I
reckon recommend if you want to read a
comedy next book this is a book that I
said I was gonna read and I think a lot
of you hopefully picked up as well
because I would love to discuss this
with someone that's read it it's live
3.0 from max tegmark which is Swedish
professor
at MIT in Boston I think he does a lot
of AI research I wanted to read this
book to learn more about AI and Max
really describes the problem that media
has really twisted the idea what we
think AI is with movies and such and
anytime AI is being spoken up you have
the the Terminator robots with the red
eyes and I think I think even in my a
eye video that I made I put that as the
thumbnail which is very cringe-worthy
now after reading this book but
nevertheless he's explaining that that's
not how a AI is going to be at all and
he goes through every single aspect of
how if we invent AI that is smarter than
a human
what sort of consequence that is going
to be AI can obviously bring us a lot of
positive and good things but there's a
lot of unanswered questions that we
haven't dealt with yet then and some
questions that are very tough but just
because they're tough doesn't mean we
shouldn't think about them professors
and researchers in AI are all kind of
torn on the issue some people say oh we
will invent AI smarter than human beings
in 100 years and some people are saying
no it won't happen until maybe a
thousand years and some people saying no
we will never be able to do that
theoretically it's possible it's not an
impossible thing and if we do invent AI
that is smarter than human beings that
is going to have a massive impact on
humanity people are saying it's gonna be
the last invention that mankind will
need to make and it's going to not just
shape humanity but also the entire
universe and following all these steps
in the book was so interesting and so
immersive it felt almost like reading a
sci-fi because some of the things
discuss are just so unbelievable the
reason why it's important that we
discuss these ideas about AI now is that
sure we invented the fire and then we
invented the fire extinguisher afterward
but in the case of AI the damage of not
being prepared could lead to
consequences that are way beyond us so
we need to start discussing these ideas
now the sooner the better basically and
it's interesting cuz apparently this
sort of issue with AI has been a very
niche idea for a long time and it's not
until recently and with the outcoming of
this book as well that it's it's again
big thankfully gotten speed I think
keeping that in mind this book is
incredibly important
basically max talks about way before we
even existed in microorganisms and the
very first set of life and then going
literally billions of years into the
future and even to the end of the
universe and these were the chapters
that I loved the the ending chapters so
fascinating I feel I feel dumbfounded
almost by so much of space that I had no
idea about and I think a lot of people
actually don't either
discussing the hypothetical ideas of
about Dyson spheres and how we could
gather energy in a more efficient way
from black holes and all these things
that just seemed so impossible but
theoretically theoretically they're
possible but now with the idea that AI
might be might be thing in the future it
actually seemed like that could actually
be a thing and that's so cool learning
about dark matter which I had no idea
about and how we don't even understand
what it is really and what implications
it has on what where we can actually
reach in space and in our universe
learning about O'Neill cylinders which
I've seen in like Syfy's and such I
didn't know there were things so
basically if you look up you'll have the
Sun in the sky even though you're living
in this I don't know weird structure in
space orbiting so cool
Maxwell's talks about conscience which I
thought was really interesting because
you're almost getting into philosophical
area of what does it mean
to have conscience can we out rule the
fact that a I will have conscience or
not how do we define it all these things
I was very very intrigued by and I want
to give this High star I feel like I
should but at the same time when you're
discussing a hypothetical scenario or
some scenario that he admits may or may
not ever happen I think max really
wanted to address every single issue
with AI he he really lays it all out on
the table but I found it sometimes to be
a bit tedious and I wish he spent more
time on other bits but I also understand
why he did that and I also think that's
it led to me unexpectedly enjoy bits
that I didn't think I would so great
book really recommend that if you're
interested in this sort of things we
have one more book guys and it's another
book that I said I was gonna read we
have Beyond Good and Evil with Frederick
Nietzsche and oh how naive I was to
think that I could read Nietzsche I
wanted to read this because I heard so
much about Nietzsche and I wanted to
leave read of philosophy I read a lot of
comments about it people saying dude you
can't just jump riding to beyond good
and evil you need to sort of ease your
way into it and it sort of made me
almost scared of reading it I was like
should I even bother like what's the
point but I thought to myself hey I said
I was gonna read the book I bought the
book why not you know even if it's too
complex for me why not give it a try
and so I tried my very best immediate to
- faced with two issues which is the
language I think I would have done
better if I read this in Swedish maybe I
had to constantly look upwards then
again he also right off the bat starts
off by analyzing other philosophers
which I'm not familiar with so it was
really hard for me to really understand
what he's trying to convey just from the
beginning I was like whoa okay and but
nevertheless there were bits that I
really did pick up on that I thought
were really interesting for example he
points out that when we look at things
like a tree for example
we don't really look at all the details
of it we sort of we don't look at the
leaves necessarily in all the branches
and he says Nietzsche says we do the
same thing when we read something we
sort of pick the words that we can
associate with things that we think we
know already
he Nietzsche points out that in that
sense we're all artists and we're all
inventors because our knowledge is
actually our own make-belief which I
thought was so true while trying to
interpret this book because the things
that I actually really picked up on
where the things that I could associate
with things I already I already knew
which is very interesting
Nietzsche believes that philosophy is
the philosopher's confession of his
character in a way and you know I wish I
may not understand everything that was
in this book but I do know that a lot of
people love Nietzsche I felt like I
could understand why people love his
character because he's very present in
this book he's very charming
I would say obviously there's a lot of
in this about religion he talks about
how we're we're atheists but we're still
religious and he points out how we we
don't really look at God as father
figure anymore and we sort of replaced
our religion with science which is oh my
god so true stupid neil degrasse tyson
there was a lot of bits that i didn't
understand at all especially the
chapters about race i talks about the
german race and how complex it is and
talked a lot about the jews and i didn't
really understand what he was trying to
say but what I do really like about
Nietzsche which I think I understand at
least is that he's ideas come from a
realist point of view and he criticized
other philosophers that sort of try and
make you feel good with her
poetic ideas almost but he wants you to
analyze what your thoughts are and where
they coming from and he also recognizes
that
we might think we know what the motive
is behind our intentions of actions but
it's actually far more complex than we
think it is which I find myself after
reading this trying to question myself
more and what what the motive behind my
intentions are and and it's been a
really fun mental exercise for me to try
and do actually so I'm really glad
despite this being clearly above my
league reading comprehension I'm really
glad I still gave it a try and I didn't
run away scared of it so did you read it
perhaps did you share my ideas what did
you pick up on what was your knowledge I
had so much fun this month too while
reading these and I had a lot of fun
today
discussing these books with you thank
you for for letting me do that and break
away from to something different I made
a list of the things that I want us to
read next month I really wanted to read
Moby Dick just an old classic thought
might be good I wanted to read another
classic which is my eye is so itchy I'm
sorry the Old Man and the sea I also
wanted to read another philosophy and a
lot of people suggested man's search for
meaning I thought as well if you maybe
don't feel like reading something as
long or something like that we would
read a Morikami
short story so I thought we would read
Toni taki Thani so maybe we can discuss
some short stories where economy has
amazing short stories and I think that's
probably want to be strength that's it
I'll see you guys next month and let me
know if you picked up any of my
recommendations or if you're going to
join me along on on these novels and
yeah thanks again really appreciate it
please do leave a like if you enjoyed
and made it this far and have brofist